>> Jimmy: COME ON.
>> IT'S SO NICE TO BE BACK HERE
WITH YOU IN NEW YORK CITY.
>> Jimmy: AND HERE WITH A LOUD
CROWD AND THE AUDIENCE.
>> AND WITH AN AUDIENCE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Jimmy: IT'S FANTASTIC.
>> YOU GUYS ARE GOOD!
>> Jimmy: THEY'RE GOOD, RIGHT?
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> REALLY GOOD.
>> Jimmy: WE FIRST MET IN THIS
BUILDING YEARS AGO ON "SATURDAY
NIGHT LIVE."
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Jimmy: YOU WERE JUST
INCREDIBLY COOL.
>> WE DID THE PROMOS TOGETHER.
STING WAS OUR MUSICAL GUEST.
>> Jimmy: WOWZERS.
>> SO THAT'S A PRETTY -- I WAS
SO OUT OF MY LEAGUE.
>> Jimmy: I HAVE -- NO.
I HAVE A PICTURE.
HERE'S YOU AND MAYA RUDOLPH.
YOU DID THIS --
>> OH, YES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE DID -- THAT WAS THE
COUNTRY -- COUNTRY MUSIC
SINGER.
WE WERE SELLING THOSE ALBUMS.
>> Jimmy: BY THE WAY --
>> LIKE THOSE INFOMERCIALS FOR
COUNTRY MUSIC ALBUMS.
>> Jimmy: LAST TIME YOU WERE
HERE WE TALKED ABOUT YOUR
SINGING.
BECAUSE ON "THE MORNING SHOW"
YOU JUST DID A BEAUTIFUL
VERSION OF --
♪ NO ONE'S GOING
TO HARM YOU ♪
>> SONDHEIM.
>> Jimmy: YES.
>> THAT WAS HARD.
>> Jimmy: IT MADE ME CRY A
A LITTLE BIT.
I LOVED IT.
>> I DID?
>> Jimmy: YEAH, I GOT CHOKED
UP.
>> I'M SO SORRY.
>> Jimmy: I LOVED IT.
NO, I LOVED IT.
BUT YOU WERE TELLING ME THAT
SOMEONE GOT YOU --
>> I HAD -- I HAD GONE TO
THIS --
BILLY CRUDUP AND I HAD TO GO
GET SINGING LESSONS WITH THIS
MAN NAMED ROGER LOVE, WHO IS A
A SINGING TEACHER.
AND I FELL IN LOVE WITH IT.
WE BOTH HAD SO MUCH FUN.
WE HAD LIKE THREE LESSONS
BEFORE WE SANG THIS.
AND THEN WE RECORDED IT.
AND IT WAS AT CAPITOL RECORDS.
WE FELT LIKE ROCK STARS.
>> Jimmy: HOW COOL IS THAT?
>> WELL, NOT REALLY ROCK STARS.
AND THEN, A FRIEND OF MINE
ACTUALLY GIFTED ME TEN SINGING
LESSONS WITH ROGER LOVE BECAUSE
I LOVED IT SO MUCH.
>> Jimmy: AND HAVE YOU --
>> WHAT A GREAT GIFT, RIGHT?
TO HAVE THAT --
IT'S LIKE --
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Jimmy: SINGING LESSONS, HAVE
YOU BEEN TAKING THEM?
>> NO.
I HAVEN'T -- I HAVEN'T TAKEN
THEM YET.
BUT I ACTUALLY DID -- MY PLAN
WAS WRAP SEASON THREE OF
"MORNING SHOW."
WRAP UP "MURDER MYSTERY" PRESS.
AND THEN, START MY -- AND HAVE
A SUMMER OF LEARNING SOMETHING
NEW.
>> Jimmy: OH, MY GOSH.
>> I KNOW.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
NEXT TIME, I'LL BE ABLE TO --
>> Jimmy: WHY NOT?
>> I'LL BE ABLE TO DO ONE OF
THOSE SINGING BITS THAT YOU DO
MAYBE NEXT TIME.
>> Jimmy: YES, WE'LL DO A
A SINGING BIT NEXT TIME
WE'RE --
ALL RIGHT, PERFECT, YEAH.
NO PRESSURE.
>> MAYBE.
>> Jimmy: NO PRESSURE.
>> DON'T HOLD ME TO THIS.
I DO LOVE YOU IN "MORNING
SHOW."
>> THANK YOU.
>> Jimmy: CAN WE SAY WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN SEASON THREE?
ANY SPOILERS?
SPOILERS?
>> SPOILERS.
>> Jimmy: WE DON'T REALLY GIVE
OUT THE SPOILERS.
>> WELL, IT'S -- THERE'S A
A LOT --
EVERYBODY HAS A SECRET.
WE'RE REVEALING A LOT OF
SECRETS.
THERE IS A LOT OF -- THERE'S
DEFINITELY ROMANCE,
MR. JON HAMM.
JON HAMM.
>> Jimmy: OH, THAT'S -- HELLO.
THAT'S WHAT I -- THAT WAS THE
BIG HEADLINE.
>> IT WAS A BIG ONE, YEAH.
WE WERE VERY EXCITED TO GET
MR. HAMM.
>> Jimmy: HE'S THE GREATEST.
>> ISN'T HE THE NICEST GUY?
>> Jimmy: HE'S SO MUCH FUN TO
HANG OUT WITH, TOO.
>> YEAH.
HE DOESN'T LOOK LIKE SOME --
YOU KNOW, HE'S THIS VERY
HANDSOME LEADING MAN.
AND THEN, HE'S GOT THIS
FUNNY --
>> Jimmy: HE'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> IT'S JUST SO FABULOUS.
>> Jimmy: SPEAKING OF FUNNY,
YOU GOT TO HONOR OUR PAL
ADAM SANDLER AT THIS PAST
WEEKEND, MARK TWAIN PRIZE IN
D.C.
THAT WAS A BIG HONOR.
>> THAT WAS A BIG HONOR.
>> Jimmy: MASSIVE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> IT WAS SO SWEET.
IT WAS REALLY EMOTIONAL -- IT
WAS MORE EMOTIONAL THAN I
EXPECTED.
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE I HADN'T BEEN
TO THE KENNEDY CENTER BEFORE.
SO THAT WAS MY FIRST TIME.
AND HERE WE ARE.
>> Jimmy: THAT'S REALLY
SPECIAL, RIGHT?
>> HONORING THE SANDMAN --
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> AT THE KENNEDY CENTER FOR
THE MARK TWAIN AWARD.
>> Jimmy: HE DRESSED UP, TOO.
I SAW HIM, HE WORE A SUIT.
>> HE WORE A SUIT.
>> Jimmy: ISN'T IT WEIRD TO SEE
HIM IN A --
>> HE NEVER WEARS A SUIT.
>> Jimmy: ISN'T IT WEIRD TO SEE
HIM IN A SUIT KIND OF?
>> IT IS WEIRD BECAUSE IT KIND
OF LOOKS LIKE HE'S JUST PLAYING
DRESS-UP.
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AND HE -- HE KIND OF JUST
SEEMS VERY UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> HE DOESN'T WANT TO WEAR A
A SUIT.
>> NO, NO.
WE HAD A DINNER IN -- WE WERE
IN ITALY DOING THE FIRST ONE.
AND IT WAS -- YOU KNOW, A NICE
DINNER WE WERE INVITED TO.
AND JACKIE LOOKED BEAUTIFUL IN
AN EYELET DRESS.
>> Jimmy: HIS WIFE, YEAH.
>> HER HAIR WAS DONE.
JACKIE SANDLER, THE AMAZING
JACKIE SANDLER.
AND HE SHOWS UP IN BASKETBALL
SHORTS.
SATIN BASKETBALL SHORTS WITH
WHITE PIPING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND NIKE HIGH TOPS, AND A
A TURQUOISE VELOUR IZOD THAT
HAD NO RELATIONSHIP TO THE
BOTTOM.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT WAS JUST --
BUT HE KIND OF, YOU KNOW,
"VOGUE" DID THIS.
"VOGUE," YOU KNOW, BASICALLY
GIVE HIM THE STYLE ICON, MADE
HIM A STYLE ICON.
>> Jimmy: THEY SAID?
>> YES.
>> Jimmy: THEY SAID BECAUSE
HE'S -- THAT'S WHAT HIS MOVE
FOREVER.
>> BUT NOW HE CAN -- NOW IT'S
HIS --
HE'S LIKE, "'VOGUE' SAID I WAS
AMAZING LIKE THIS."
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: THAT'S NOT --
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> SO, THANKS, "VOGUE."
THAT'S TRUE.
>> Jimmy: YOU'VE KNOWN EACH
OTHER FOR YEARS, YOU AND ADAM.
>> OVER 30 YEARS.
>> Jimmy: YEAH.
>> WE MET AT JERRY'S DELI ON
VENTURA BOULEVARD WHEN WE WERE
20 AND 22.
>> Jimmy: NO WAY.
[ AUDIENCE AWWs ]
>> YEAH.
>> Jimmy: JERRY'S FAMOUS DELI.
THAT'S WILD.
AND OVER THE YEARS, HAVE YOU
GIVEN EACH OTHER ADVICE OR
HELPED EACH OTHER THROUGHOUT
YOUR CAREERS?
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO?
>> WELL, IF I GET ANYTHING FROM
HIM, IT'S "WHAT ARE YOU DOING?"
USUALLY BASED ON SOMEONE I'M
DATING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU?
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT I VERY MUCH LOVE TO TAKE
CARE OF HIM.
HE'S SO CONCERNED WITH TAKING
CARE OF EVERYBODY ELSE, WHICH
HE REALLY DOES.
>> Jimmy: BUT HIMSELF.
>> AND HE DOESN'T TAKE CARE OF
HIMSELF.
I'M SORRY TO CALL YOU OUT ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION, ADAM.
BUT YOU HAVE TO KNOW THIS.
AND I HAVE A -- OUR LITTLE
ARSENAL OF HERBS IN MY TRAILER
AND I MAKE HIM SMOOTHIES WHEN I
CAN.
AND GIVE HIM ALL SORTS OF LIKE
CHINESE HERBS WHEN HE'S
EXHAUSTED.
SO, I DON'T KNOW.
I'M LIKE THE LITTLE -- I'M LIKE
THE MOBILE PHARMACY.
I'M THE SET MEDIC.
>> Jimmy: THAT'S SO NICE OF YOU
TO DO THAT FOR HIM.
>> I KNOW, ISN'T IT?
>> Jimmy: TAKE CARE OF THE
SANDLER.
>> AND JACKIE'S LIKE, "THANKS,
IT LASTED ABOUT A MINUTE."
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: HE DOESN'T DO
SMOOTHIES.
HE DOESN'T --
>> YEAH.
>> Jimmy: CAN WE TELL EVERYONE
WHAT'S GOING ON "MURDER MYSTERY
2."
THE FIRST ONE WAS A GLOBAL
SUCCESS.
BIGGER THAN ANYTHING.
>> WHOA.
>> Jimmy: IT WAS MASSIVE, I
MEAN, OVER "STRANGER THINGS,"
IT WAS A BIG DEAL.
>> WHOA.
>> Jimmy: YEAH, OH, YEAH.
AND SO, "MURDER MYSTERY 2" IS
NOW DOUBLE THE ACTION.
>> DOUBLE THE ACTION, IT'S A --
YES, THERE'S A LOT OF ACTION.
THAT'S -- THAT MEANS STUNTS.
AND --
>> Jimmy: HOW ARE YOU DOING
YOUR OWN STUNTS?
YOU LOOK GREAT IN --
>> WELL, I DO ENJOY -- I HAVE
AN INCREDIBLE STUNT DOUBLE,
KELLY, WHO JUST BASICALLY WORKS
WITH ME AND --
IT'S NOT THAT -- I WASN'T
JUMPING OUT OF A BUILDING.
I MEAN, SHE DID -- SHE REPELLED
UP THE ACTUAL SIDE OF THE
EIFFEL TOWER.
>> Jimmy: YOU JUMP OFF -- YOU
FALL OFF THE EIFFEL TOWER.
>> I JUMP ONTO MARK STRONG'S
BACK TO SAVE THE DAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: YES, THAT'S WHAT I
MEANT.
>> I MEAN -- LIKE -- OH, SHOOT.
WELL, ANYWAY, I GET --
SOMETHING HAPPENS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: BUT YOU ARE -- WE CAN
SAY THIS, YOU ARE ON THE TOP OF
THE EIFFEL TOWER.
>> YES, THERE'S A LOT
HAPPENING.
AND ADAM DID A LOT OF HIS OWN
STUNTS.
AND HE GETS PRETTY BEAT UP.
I MEAN, HE ACTUALLY GOT HIT.
DID HE EVER TELL YOU ABOUT
MARK STRONG ACTUALLY HIT HIM IN
THE FACE.
>> Jimmy: NO.
>> PRETTY HARD.
>> Jimmy: NO WAY.
>> YEAH, I SAW IT.
HE CRIED, LITTLE TEAR.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: HE DID CRY, YEAH.
BUT YOU GUYS HAVE GREAT
CHEMISTRY.
>> WE HAVE FUN TOGETHER.
>> Jimmy: IT'S AWESOME TO SEE
YOU GUYS.
AND EVERYONE LOVES IT.
IT'S GOOD.
SO, IN THIS ONE, YOU
ACTUALLY -- NOW YOU'RE GOING TO
TRY TO BE A DETECTIVE.
>> YEAH, WELL, NOW WE DECIDED
AFTER THE LAST ONE THAT WE'RE
REALLY GOOD AT THIS.
AND SO, WE'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY
OPEN UP OUR OWN LITTLE
DETECTIVE AGENCY.
AND WE ARE WHAT -- WHEN YOU
MEET US -- WHEN YOU MEET BACK
UP WITH US, WE'RE NOT DOING
THAT GREAT.
>> Jimmy: NO.
>> SO, WE GET INVITED TO A
A WONDERFUL WEDDING OF SOMEONE
WONDERFUL.
AND WE SAY WE NEED A BREAK.
WE NEED A VACATION.
>> Jimmy: LET'S JUST GET A
A VACATION.
>> AND THEN, THAT'S WHERE OUR
BIGGEST MISTAKES HAPPEN.
>> Jimmy: YEAH, HIJINKS ENSUE.
>> WE DON'T MAKE VERY GOOD
DECISIONS.
>> Jimmy: NO, NO, NO.
>> BUT IT TURNS OUT WELL.
>> Jimmy: IT IS SO FUNNY, AND
ALSO I COMPLIMENTED YOUR
SINGING EARLIER, BUT YOU'RE
DANCING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> MY BOLLYWOOD DANCE?
>> Jimmy: YES, GET READY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
YOU'RE GOING TO LOVE THIS
MOVIE.
I WANT TO SHOW EVERYONE A CLIP.
HERE'S JENNIFER ANISTON AND
ADAM SANDLER IN "MURDER MYSTERY
2."
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> UH-HUH.
>> OH, BOY.
>> OKAY, SO THAT MOAT'S LIKE,
THREE METERS?
I THINK I CAN CLEAR THAT.
>> NICK, THREE METERS IS LIKE
TEN FEET.
>> I HAD THE HIGH SCHOOL RECORD
FOR THE LONG JUMP.
AND I'M NOT KIDDING YOU, I WENT
FURTHER THAN THAT BACK IN THE
DAY.
>> DID YOU?
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT DID YOU CALL YOU BACK
THEN?
NICKY LONG LEGS?
>> YOU MOCKING ME?
>> BUT I'M JUST TELLING YOU,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE THAT
JUMP.
>> IT DOESN'T A MAKE ME FEEL
GOOD TO PROVE YOU WRONG.
BUT I'M GOING TO GO DO THAT.
ALL RIGHT?
>> UH-HUH, UH-HUH.
>> OKAY, FROM THAT ANGLE IT
DOES LOOK LIKE FURTHER THAN
THREE METERS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jimmy: COME ON.
JENNIFER ANISTON, "MURDER
MYSTERY 2" PREMIERES GLOBALLY
ON NETFLIX MARCH 31st.
SARAH SNOOK JOINS US AFTER THE
BREAK.
STICK AROUND, EVERYBODY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]